Doing too good,
just starts to get started everything
again.
Mhm.
Yeah, so are you feeling better now, yeah?
Oh yeah,
I started working on the front end and
then I set up a couple of stuffs and then
I'm almost done with making all the
Mmh.
components. Like, you know, for example,
I've chose the colour code and I have
So.
generated some components like buttons
and all everything.
Like I know what font I'm using and
everything.
This much I have done and then from
tonight, like from today,
Yes.
I'll start doing like the page design 1
by 1.
Uh-huh.
So that's all the.
Yeah.
Yeah, so, yeah,
so you mean that you're almost finished
with the design for the website, yeah?
Yeah,
I just like all the components are ready,
like 90% of my components are ready.
I just need to just some of the stuff's
left as part load and then I'm going to
start the page designs, but all my color,
what should be the colour code,
colour combination,
everything that's ready. It just,
I just need to, yeah,
I just need to just design the things now.
Like I know what colour I'm going to put
Hey, that's good.
on. It just need to.
You know, need to design and with Figma,
yeah,
I'm not that much obviously pro with
Figma, but yeah.
Just looking on that.
Uh, yeah.
Yeah, at least you know how to.
I haven't used Figma before,
so at least you have someone who knows
how to go around with it.
Mhm.
Yeah, yeah,
that I know how to use and I've got a
friend who is like pro with Figma.
So if I'm having an issue, I ask him like,
okay, how to do that? He's like, okay,
this is that. Like he's a designer,
Oh.
professional designer. So it's like,
you know,
it's a daily job to work with Figma.
Yes.
So, how about you, MD? How are you?
I'm good, how are you?
And for last two days I was not there.
Mm.
Yeah, I'm good, yeah.
And now I am free today.
I can work today and tomorrow also.
Yep.
And I will start today.
Can you tell us what are the current
status and what we have done so far?
Yeah,
so mostly a sprint one is almost finished.
It's just the testing on your side.
I finish most of the most of them,
You.
I see.
but you can cheque the I created like a
Excel spreadsheet.
Are you testing?
Okay.
So, um,
you have there that is written that there
is an owner and such. Um,
let me just pull it up.
Okay.
That is.
What is the Excel sheet? Can you share?
It's in the documents and testing part.
Yep.
Oh, okay, okay.
Let me just pull it up real quick and
share my screen.
The string.
Yeah.
Every dance, yeah, I got it.
Yep.
So yeah,
mostly some things here that should be
Yeah.
yours,
but I was able to do it because I was
already working on some stuff.
So I just created it, yeah.
Okay,
is that is that for a spin to one or is?
This is for Sprint One.
Okay.
Yeah, so mostly I've done it already.
Okay.
So you just have to do yours here.
So I think I was able to create 2 here
OKOK.
for that should be yours,
but I made them because I was already
working on that part already, so.
Yeah.
OK, I'll do it,
and now let's get back to Sprint Two,
Yeah.
and what's the plan for Sprint Two?
How can we move forward?
Yes, please.
Yeah, so Sprint 2, the real owner of 5.
2 was you,
the career and skill reference data.
Good point, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
But, because...
Yeah, so because I have,
I don't have any work this weekend until
today.
Yeah.
I started working on that so I can work
on 5.3 and 5.5 because it's blocking.
Yeah.
Then I I will start from 5.
2 career at least for instant.
No, I've...
Yeah, I've already finished 5.2 and 5.
3 because instead of me waiting again,
I miss all.
I've done it so I can be able to move on
with some of the things. So you can, yeah,
OKOK.
Just.
Okay, then we start from 5.4.
so you can still 5.4 and 5.7, I think,
is yours. So you can still do those.
One, OK.
Okay.
And I'm almost finished with 5.5.
Point 5,
still gap and readiness is scoring.
Yeah, so I'm almost done.
Yep, almost done with that one.
So, what I can do now is...
While we,
while Joy is still doing some of the
design.
Okay.
Yeah.
I can work some of the 5.6.
5.6. OK.
So, yeah.
I like what I will suggest to you guys is
just give me like one more week.
One more week means like till Friday.
I'll try to finish at least some of the
Mhm.
pages.
I think I can do that because I got
pretty a little bit of time this week.
So I'll try to do at least a couple of
Yeah.
pages so that we have something for like
bigger husband to is finishing on Friday,
right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
so it I will have some contribution on
sprint tools.
Green.
Yep, so we still have, we still have 5.
6 and 5.8 for Sprint 2 on front end.
Thanks.
All.
So...
A strong.
Yeah, I'll cheque that.
Actually, honestly,
I'm going going with whatever Claude is
Yeah.
Oh.
telling me, you know what I mean,
because I had no clue with the first
Fourth September or Spring Blue?
thing.
Yeah, I understand, yep.
Yeah, like it's Friday.
Yeah, we can do that. I'll just work on 5.
5 and I'll hold off on working 5.6 and 5.
8, so you can do those.
Five, 6, one.
Yeah,
so those are our front-end interfaces,
so yeah,
mostly Joy is the one really who needs to
do this, but if...
Is Joy working for with working on a
mock-up only or front-end react part?
Yeah, I'm sorry, front-end, yeah.
Yeah, front end, she, yeah,
she's the leader of the front end, yep.
All.
Okay.
So what I do is I support both front and
back end and also do some of the high
levels. So I will just be doing 5.5.
When I finish this,
Okay.
I'll just continue doing some of the
testing plans instead of working on for 5.
Okay.
6. And if you guys need help, you know,
you just reach out.
This.
So, yeah, at least now, yeah,
we don't have any more blockage, so...
That sounds OK, I guess, yeah.
5.4
Or 7.
And he can do that one.
For 5.7, is there any dependency? Like 5,
no, 5.5 is a dependency. Is 5.5 finished?
I almost done, I can finish it today.
Ohh.
Okay, okay.
Then we can finish the Sprint 2 backend.
In this week, or maybe...
Yeah, so once.
tomorrow or day after tomorrow.
I try to finish tomorrow or day after
Yeah, so...
tomorrow.
Yeah, so.
And then we going back to move to testing
for Sprint Two, which is 5.9, then review,
Mhm.
and then complete, yeah,
because I want that we have to finish as
Yeah.
Yeah, so...
After 5 points.
much.
as early as possible because we have to
set target like we have to finish it's
Yeah.
like week 9 or week 10.
Then we have we get some time for
Yeah.
reviewing, finalising and...
Yeah,
at least you have to be able to like
Yeah, testing. Yeah. Yeah.
testing and edit stuff if we need to fix
bugs.
Yeah, yeah.
Yes, yeah, are you recording the meeting?
Yep.
Yeah, I started recording earlier.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
and put it into OneDrive.
Okay, that's great.
I completely forgot about that.
Yeah, I know it's recording. Yes,
it said stop recording, so it's good, yep.
No, yeah.
So yeah, actually after 5.5,
I'll be starting doing the planning for
Yes.
integration and testing.
Okay.
And.
But.
So, that's gonna take...
And 5.3 is finished.
5.3 is finished, yep, yep,
so you can do the 5.4 and...
Right, OK, OK, then I restart from 5.
4 and then move to.
I'll be finishing 5.5,
then you'll be able to do the 5.7 on it,
By person.
Yeah, sure, sure.
yeah.
So, yep, I think we're good. Joy,
if you weren't,
Yeah.
if you cannot finish some on Friday,
you can just reach me out. I can.
Yeah.
I'll update you guys by, yeah,
I'll update you by Wednesday,
how much I've finished,
or Wednesday or Thursday.
I'll just let you know that because
Friday, I don't think so.
I'll be able to talk to you guys because
I got the longest shift on Friday.
But on Thursday,
I'll confirm you how far I've done.
Yep.
And I'll share everything, I think,
by today.
Mhm.
By tonight.
Yeah, that's good, yep.
Like the Figma file and everything,
like whatever is happening back there,
so that you can also view as a you can
view the stars.
Yeah, also, can I ask,
have you joined the uh...
I'm sorry, just somewhere. Yeah.
Uh, get up already.
Are you able to,
are you able to join the GitHub already?
Sorry?
Yeah?
Yeah, I have already done. Like,
I don't know for the first time,
Yeah, in okay, yeah.
or it has an issue. But invitation,
I clearly remember.
I separated the last time when I was
doing this work with someone.
I had to like ask them for three times
because it was expiring,
Mhm.
although it expires in seven days,
but mine was expiring only for that
But here it shows only.
Yeah.
reason.
Yeah, but this time was fine.
I don't know why that happened.
Both of us.
Yeah, so, yeah.
And.
Maybe.
Also make sure that you can post
something on GitHub because I think on
Thank you so much.
the 17th.
I have not, ohh,
I haven't done anything here.
Yeah, we we will have like, yeah,
we have another progress report,
so you can add, you can know,
do your progress report and individual
Yes.
Yeah.
report, you can show something.
Yeah.
Mm.
So you can just put in the documents
about the designs that you do.
At least those are like evidence for you.
Yeah, no,
that that should I do at least like my
That you're doing something.
components and stuff.
These are like very bold things for
Yeah.
design. Yeah, these are these are ready.
I can just show that.
Yeah.
Then you put your draught in the OneDrive.
Me?
Yeah,
your draught and other like exercise file,
you can put it in OneDrive and some of
final draught are uploaded in GitHub.
Yeah,
or maybe I can like post some like
screenshot and I can make a PDF or
something and then I'll upload it on.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you can upload it also on GitHub or in
OneDrive because it's also linked in,
yeah.
I.
Yeah, okay.
Alright,
do you have any more uh like question
Yep.
guys?
Ohh, no, nothing from me.
No.
Okay, I'm also good.
Not from my side, yeah, good.
Yep.
I'll just finish 5.
5 later and update you guys. All right.
Thanks.
Yeah, yeah, sure, sure.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Okay guys, bye.
Thank you. Bye.
Right.